well you can see it with debt
I mean we make less money than men but
we spend more money yeah I mean the
world pay is not insecurities so yeah
it's a great whale that's like a back to
a victim mentality no no but I mean in
the sense that you know we you know if
you want to get down to it I just want
to be a natural woman of no hit with
that no makeup no wigs like no not
shaving not doing anything I want to do
it comes ties into what's attractive
what men like so we've been sold a story
of to be to be a wife to be a woman to
be attractive with these things and I
feel like a lot of the things that women
buy into whether it be the BBL the
makeup the wigs the hair the tan the the
toenails the everything to the clothes
we wear it constantly feels into to debt
but it's so freeing when you're like
effort that and it's gonna be me so
however we sold a story when there's
movements like body positivity what do
you mean so if we're sold the story of
what men like and it's for men and the
media is for men and we're sold a story
about what men like like why is there
body positivity because as I said women
I feel like they're going against that
exactly I feel like body positivity
isn't for the women that are
conventionally pretty or beautiful is
for women that are saying you know I'm
not the Kim K's or the whoever out there
the bad bees on Instagram I'm a woman
and I'm going to be put and I'm gonna
celebrate my my body and who I am that's
the story we're seeing in the media
70 to 80 of consumer buying decisions
are made by women everything we see in
the media is marketed towards women yeah
but who's making their decisions not
women who makes the decision women do at
the end of the day because women they
spend their money the decisions come
with where the money we spoke about the
majority of women want to get married
want to be wise want to be a certain way
want to be a certain thing therefore if
they're gonna you're gonna create a
story about using scream and you'll be a
better wife you used to buy these shoes
you'll be a better girlfriend you're
gonna buy interviews you have to take
responsibility for your own actions it's
like again you're pushing the blame onto
something I'm not pushing the black I'm
not pushing no because maybe because I
work in the industry where we sometimes
you what you want me to think a certain
way even if podcasts or whatever people
say certain things get people to think a
certain way I'm not talking about the
exception I'm not talking about
exceptions to the world about the masses
the Masters are told be a woman be a
wife be a mum and or to be these things
buy this stuff but that's not what we're
told with feminism we're told chase the
back I've been told from a young age
chase the bag you can do whatever you
want there's women empowerment there's
not men empowerment I'm back but don't
do it I mean there's there's I don't
know is there not men I don't know you
got that one there I'm not gonna say
anything and it's not and and honestly
in society that's not true if you see
anyone shame sex work on social media
what happens the comments is filled with
people saying you're what slut-shaming
I didn't see that stuff
there's a ton of social conventions that
protect women from a lot of these for a
lot of these things and again like he
said body positivity positivity is one
of many but we're saying basically
because for so long as a woman I mean I
could say I always speak as a black
woman growing up I didn't see no black
women on TV let alone if it was a black
woman TV it was Tyra Banks it will
damick Campbell and all I saw for a very
very long time if I'm not seeing you
didn't watch Oprah no I mean
no okay so and it says like so great
even and in the UK it was worse so the
UK there was like I grew up in the 90s
and early 2000s I'm saying UK so UK she
has two thousands I was really grown by
then okay but great because I asked my
mom when I was very young where are
black people on TV where where am I so I
was very conscious of that from very
young so it's not seeing not seeing
myself my skin tone my my shape on TV
was a lot for me so now that I'm saying
women that celebrate the way I look
because I don't look I'm not I'm not a
10 out of 10 and I can tell it on the
chin I'm good with that so when I look
the size like the size I I am I'm a
plumper woman I'm a bigger woman I'm a
darker woman seen that now on TV and
being positive has done me the world of
good not because I want to get a man but
I said Okay I I I
um and there's more people like me out
there because I'm coming from a white
neighborhood I didn't think people was
like me out there but now on social
media I do see that and it's better for
me so just a question why does it matter
because I'm I've read her and I don't
really see tall pale gingers on TV and I
just don't care like what does it matter
if I see someone on TV that looks like
me I feel like it could be quite
damaging as well like if you've been
especially for like a lot of people are
color-like the shows you've watched like
it's not you're not seeing yourself and
it's something it is sometimes like
maybe younger you would have been nice
just to see like a redhead acting but oh
my God like it's just it's just a bit
more it's not a big thing but even like
just little things like you'll see now
with the movies they make and the people
they cast you'll see little children
growing up to be just uplifted by that
film and that could become their comfort
film and that motivation like I I'm not
this I'm not ugly because how can I be
ugly when a B and C are on the TV screen
right but the reason we brought this up
is we were talking about women spending
too much money yeah and so what
no because I I said that because you
were you were sort of saying we spend
more money because of society and so
then it kind of led into body positivity
but I'm saying what does that have to do
with spending like us spending too much
money I just feel like that's our own
decisions and we spend too much money
because we're bad with money not not
because of society oh it's not bad with
money I don't know yeah because I think
there's a part of our brain that like
lights up with impulse decisions that
doesn't for men but do you mean in the
sense if we spend more money because of
society because we're trying to reach
the standard that we think Society
expects yes that's why we spend more
money because yeah no I think we spend
more money because we're bad with money
one of the number one ways that women
are in debt is college debt in the US
anyway that's nothing to do and when I'm
having these shoot when I'm having these
conversations I'm talking about the West
so UK and and the us because I'm from
the US yeah but I just think women like
every girl I know is bad with money
oh my God oh my God yeah I give my money
to a girl I'm I'm by the money yeah I am
bad I am I'm the kind of person why is
that so why um because I grew up poor so
now that I have money I want to spend it
and things I couldn't get when I was
when I was poor simple as that it was
time to come to eat so now I can't eat
I'm gonna buy it every week everything I
want because I can that's my thing I
couldn't buy certain clothes now I can
I'm gonna buy it that's what I'm doing
that's what I'm bad when does that stop
for you it's stopping now because I'm 35
and I've got to retire soon so for me
I'm not conversation I can't also I make
more money never met before so for me I
can't make it by decisions on my spend
ahead because I want to get old one day
I will not have to work hard anymore
that's what I've changed so that's why
I've added money but now I've got I've
got friends that are women more than men
are good man I give them much hold this
for me and say it for me until I learned
to save that touch of money I don't
think it's women are bad women up about
money amazing I know a better money than
men are in my opinion how can you argue
that when the fact is that most of
Consumer Debt if talked about women
I I'm saying that I'm I'm not arguing
I'm saying I don't think I don't think
many men don't spend but maybe I don't
remember to spend on saying that my plan
that I'd be like women that I know
people that I know women are better than
men my mom my aunts they can save money
they can the men will go and try and
flip the money try and sow the money try
and become an entrepreneur the woman's
at home counting the pennies make sure
all the bills are paid that's how I
thought I've seen right I think
sometimes in the older generation that's
a thing but with women women my age are
terrible with money they're always on
what's it called Sheen oh [ __ ]
and like the girls I know they spend
money like it's water but is that not
because of society as well that they're
like so women feel like they can't wear
an outfit more than once yes because
they'll post a picture on Instagram
whatever and so that's all Society LED
and therefore they're constantly buying
new things it's other women it's not for
the men it's other women do you guys
care if your girl wears the same outfit
ever every day
as long as she washes it's good to go on
it yeah
women
I think it's because they make poor
choices and they don't have any
self-control
I'm like I don't accountability yeah
it's definitely some women
um the women that I I am around
um they they they're not like that
they're very much um good with money
it's more it's more for me it's the men
that I'm around because we make a
certain amount of money and some men are
are crazy crazy stupid of the money
um I'll give you an example
um a member
uh the first uh when I moved away so I
was a plane I was painting I was playing
premier league and then the first
um the first month we got paid because
they get paid monthly whereas in the UK
you get paid weekly the first month we
got paid a few a few days after one of
um one of my teammates came up to me and
says
um I'm I need more money and I'm just
like what do you mean you need more
money what did you do with your money he
said I just blew I just blew 6K I'm like
like how what did you do with it you
said women
um he went out he so anyways that's
that's his poor decisions
um mostly the way the way I grew up is
is the women that that that that are
more financially literate yeah they they
the one that that handled the money
they're the one that that distribute the
money and especially coming from I'm
originally Congolese so
um the way in our cultural well it's
changing now but the way the way it used
to be the man will go to work the woman
will go to the market the man will come
back home
um he'll put the money on the table
um okay this is the money that I've made
and then the woman would then distribute
like this money is for the rent this
money is for food this money is that in
the other right well I'm happy that
you're around exceptions but it's not
the rule
no women still own the majority of
Consumer Debt you you've also got to
take into account that you're you're
around footballers yeah who have a
tendency and a reputation not to spend
money well in terms of how they end up
after their career yeah yeah so so like
I can understand you with your point of
view where you find that the men around
you are spending my money frivolously
women are saving it as well that many
more likely to pursue high risk High
reward as well so if my household my dad
was the entrepreneur whilst my mom
worked so naturally he's going to spend
a lot more money than my mom would but
at the same time when it's successful
we're good to go and the other thing is
with with the man when he spent that
money Society doesn't say it's Society
making you spend that money well I mean
they just say it's your poor decisions
like this this no no guy is gonna talk
to his guy friend and say oh it's
Society making you spend the money okay
no if you just get the poor choice yeah
you're right it's point it's poor poor
choices I 100 agree with you but when
you're going to say no no but when you
guys said about you never been to the
club when guys are popping balls it's
all girls pooping balls it's really not
it's like I've been out in front of 10K
in one night I'm looking around like
what's your point though so you're
saying you're saying that um you're
saying that men don't make rest
decisions they don't impulse biology
nobody do when you go to the club they
do right I'm saying by and large men
make better financial decisions than
women and we can see this because men
make more money and they and they spend
less women make less money and they
spend more so by and large women make
worse financial decisions I think it's
because women generally are trying to
compensate for something I don't know
what but I think that's what it comes
from I think it's because women lack
self-control what do you think yeah I
think we're trying to satisfy something
we're trying to buy the latest outfit
buy the latest Botox you know how many
girls I know that get BOTOX at like 24
25 26 and they can't afford it it's not
like they're making enough money it's
all for attention I thought about it but
every like just younger people in
general how do you afford all this stuff
they can't I could not and I cannot I
don't understand how do they do it all
that's the point they can't the people
that have that fast lifestyle like I
grew up in a one percent family I know I
know what money looks like and I'm
telling you the richest people I know
don't spend money like that I know
someone that's worth probably 50 to 75
million roughly and they've driven the
same car for 20 years
like it's just a mentality it's
definitely if you haven't had it you're
always gonna want if you haven't had it
you're gonna want to try and get it and
then and somehow unfortunately if you
haven't come you've come from a place
where you don't have it those stuff
those things make you feel good
unfortunately and it's very sad that we
live in the western Society we're having
things having stuff makes you feel good
about yourself rather than having
character and being a person not
necessarily that just comes with
self-reflection and and again
understanding yourself so a lot of
people in the west arguably aren't
self-aware we just do things we don't
think about why we do them hence why
we're having this conversation a lot of
girls will go out and just do things and
not think about the consequences so you
spend without thinking about the
consequences you do only friends that I
think are the consequences all these
things are a lack of cognitive cognition
and making good decisions for yourself
yeah it's just women are always bailed
out for bad decision we always have an
excuse for women and we never do for men
wow and we can even in this conversation
nobody when he was talking about his
friend that spent the money nobody in
the room said oh well it's Society
making him spend it but everyone when we
talked about it that other way around oh
it's Society making her spend it I think
men like his friend that that spent a
lot of money had difficult complex I'd
say the guy that put bottles in the club
they have a complex that they're trying
to fulfill by popping their bottles or
getting the batteries on the table it's
a complex we just I think where women
have been
I've been hunt to a corner to admit it
men have to I haven't got to admit yet
but most money the family review I
wanted that bad as it'd be so I bought a
bottle of champagne I wanted to think so
I'm the guy in the club but we're not
ready to really Flex conversations yet I
think we've never thought about poppy
bottles don't even get the girl anyway
so what are you saying what yeah for
sure it's just yeah but then they'll
come to your table if you don't action
after that's your business but you'll
get the girl to your table at least
where the girl grabs her drink and
leaves
yeah well known the popping bottle
things okay like certain men to display
ego and to display power and presence
they'll do these things
but again like if they can afford to do
it it is what it is but then if you
can't afford to do that's another
question but based on the information
provided most men are more likely to be
able to afford to be that frivolous
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible